so as russia runs into some serious
headway and some big losses of their
equipment on the battlefield vladimir
putin is looking for a beijing bailout
fox news confirming that russia asked
china for military and economic aid
after the the invasion but china pushed
back on that report calling it malicious
disinformation from the united states
the news has u.s officials alarmed white
house national security adviser jake
sullivan rushed to a meeting with his
chinese counterpart in rome and has this
warning
we are communicating directly privately
to beijing
that there will absolutely be
consequences for
large-scale sanctions invasion efforts
or support to russia to backfill them we
will not allow that to go forward and
allow there to be
a lifeline to russia from these economic
sanctions from any country anywhere in
the world
so the white house describing the
meeting as between sullivan and this top
chinese diplomat as quote intense it
lasted for seven hours that's a lot of
meeting uh jesse what do you think about
this scramble well it's a great piece of
intel that we picked up it's you know
amazing what our intelligence agencies
can do when they're not trying to frame
donald trump and i like the fact that we
put the chinese on blast right away and
say we caught you cold and we know what
you're up to and now the europeans have
to think yeah china's going to fund a
proxy war in europe that's not going to
be good for business either
russia must be in a pretty weak position
if they're asking for beijing to bail
them out their military-industrial
complex must be running on fumes they
usually sell arms to china it usually
doesn't go the other way around so china
knows that russia made a mistake and
they know that they're kind of in bed
with this war criminal and do they want
to be an armed supplier and an arms
dealer for a warm criminal i don't think
they do and the stock market's getting
absolutely hammered
in china right now all these assets that
could be sanctioned are exposed and it's
a risky bet to align themselves with the
russians and you can see i think they
had the worst day since 2008
so they lost about 2 trillion since the
year started because they're exposed
with them
i think the way that china gets out of
this is they have to realize this thing
in ukraine is making america strong it's
uniting nato and they could become
encircled if they don't play their cards
right so i would suggest chi because i
know he watches the five he does he
should negotiate this thing out of here
he has leverage over putin if he could
get putin to pull back some way somehow
that would make the chinese look a lot
better because they didn't look so good
after covet that's likely janine
you know what i do agree with jesse i'll
tell you you know initially when china
didn't rebuke po putin when everybody
else was doing it and they also
abstained from multiple votes to censure
russia you know you got the sense that
you know there's something going on and
our intelligence indicates that there's
something going on but i think xi
jinping is smart enough to understand
that as
nato has in some way strengthen the
western world that they don't want to be
in a position where they're undermining
our sanctions against russia because
they're going to suffer economically and
and financially and so i i absolutely
agree i think it's not in their best
interest you know greg
when you look at this china really
doesn't have to
do whatever russia says right right um
they can sort of be there like you know
the junior partner and they can make
them beg for whatever they need from
china but they both made it pretty clear
before the olympics they came out and
said you know
this is our message to the rest of the
global leadership world are they going
to break up engagement do not interfere
with this
china china is michael douglas and fatal
attraction
china is a person who regrets the one
one-night stand in this case they hooked
up with a russian gymnast at the
olympics they thought they figured oh
this is they figured this would be a
24-hour incursion right they were you
know just you know it'll be quick it'll
be just like crimea no now it's a month
of pain suffering embarrassment
humiliation it's ultimately going to be
a stain on your character if you hang
out with this who do you sleep with
china you don't want is this the type of
crowd you want to hang with right now
russia has foreign policy std
you just don't want to get in bed with
it until at least until the episode
heals and the sooner it heals the better
for everybody involved i do welcome
china getting involved in this because
if biden and she could could could
somehow join forces here it would it
would probably help but i i kind of
remember when china was the bad partner
fentanyl kovid uyghurs they might
actually might be kind of grateful the
heat's not on putin made china look good
and that's hard to do it is jessica
well china's also in huge panic about
taiwan right now so they're sitting
there watching what's going on saying oh
well we have a sovereign country that we
think is ours too
and where is the how is the world going
to respond if we start moving on taiwan
and obviously
they would be capable of taking over
taiwan it would not be what's going on
in the ukrainians have put up such a
valiant fight and i i think a lot about
i mean not too much but a good amount
about what that phone call looked like
between she and putin when the olympics
were coming where she said could you
just wait until the olympics are over
and putin said yeah no big deal it's a
48-hour job right and and will be done
and she said sure no problem and that it
would go the way of crimea and it
probably i mean he might have even
started saying it's just going to be
those eastern provinces the places that
already have pro-russian militaries and
uh governments in place and we'll go
about our business the chinese economy
is
obviously took that hit but it is on the
upward trajectory and she doesn't want
to rock the boat too far on that they
also have an increasing covert problem
which we were talking about thousands of
people are getting hospitalized and
we're getting more accurate information
about what's going on in china than we
did obviously the first time around
and that puts tremendous strain on a
country as we know well you know having
lost over 600 thousand lives here um so
i think xi jinping is probably pretty
annoyed at putin for misrepresenting
what he was doing here since they have
the strong alliance and it's the
situation which is so poorly read by
putin and that's what all of these
russia analysts seem to be saying he can
still back what they're doing and say
look you're in your own neighborhood you
believe ukraine is part you know that's
fine but but don't look to us we're not
going to do anything else for you and
they'll still have not going to
accept that
friendship at this point when you're
losing this badly and you're an autocrat
sitting alone in a room means what are
you going to give me not just that
you're not going to publicly
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else